All right, that wall is in and done,...
...now we just need to start this section up here.
Van-life lesson number three:
Donkeys eat wood and anything else they can get their teeth on.
So, make sure to put all your supplies away at the end of the day.
We really came to cherish this routine during our van build.
Waking up each morning to feed Myrtle and Nush Nush,...
...and working together all day as a team.
Before long, the ceiling was done and the walls of our new home took shape.
In the afternoons, I cook us lunch while Lou stayed back...
...to make sure that the donkeys didn't eat all of our supplies.
Last screw, and I feel like it is starting to look like a home.
Still messy but the van-life experience has begun, which is really exciting.
And this is a ton of work so it feels like a huge part of the build is behind us,...
...and we're getting to the fun stuff like painting,...
...and building the kitchen, and putting in the bed,...
...and all that good stuff that makes it truly feel like a home.
So yeah, big project done, and a lot more to come.